[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Beverly's
in Dallas hi Beverly welcome to the
Ramsey show thank you thank you for
taking my call sure what's
up well I'm a little bit different than
a lot of your callers I'm 74 years old
and I wish to goodness I'd started
listening to you 20 years ago but I
didn't so I'm starting today okay um I
have about 30 2,
$31,995 to Biga in uh credit card
debt and I know that I want to get busy
and as you say gazelle like and paying
that
off but I also have $
57,6 123 left on my house Dave I'm 74
and I'm in good health I want to pay off
all this credit card debt but is it okay
okay if I just continue making payments
on my house while I'm still young enough
and healthy enough to travel and do
things and then pay for it I mean
obviously continue making payments but
you know what I'm saying yeah but they
you know the more stable your last your
the the the sooner your house is paid
off the more stable your last year's
will
be right and so that's the tradeoff uh
obviously you need to clean the credit
CR card debt up before we talk about
travel right okay but right and do you
have any
money um I do I I am I'm I'm retired and
um I have like 400 25,000 in um a an
annuity with a it's a fixed index
annuity with a lifetime writer yeah pay
both pay both the loans off
tomorrow do what pay both the loans off
tomorrow okay out of that
annuity and I have um about
$40,000 in stocks uh Texon and Computer
Share stocks okay I would cash that out
and pay and then take a little more out
of the annuity and um and make sure you
have an emergency fund set aside and
you're 100% debt free by the end of the
week no mortgage no credit cards cut up
the credit cards Beverly it's time for
plastic surgery not because you're 74
but because you use credit
cards well here's I haven't used those
credit cards in about three years asked
my my sister to help me and at the time
I asked her to help me I had about
$23,000 in credit card debt and her
suggestion was to get a credit card and
have all my bills just go to that and so
your sister's not very good at this well
there she and her husband are
millionaires which is why I asked well
her her her her Theory took you from 23
to 32 so her idea sucks yeah for me it
sure well I'm just saying you need to
cut up the credit cards completely get
you a debit card like I use and like Ken
uses and a debit card you have to you
have to only spend money that you have
chop up all the credit cards into little
bitty pieces take out that those stocks
and enough out of the annuities to pay
off your mortgage and your credit cards
this week be living on a budget where
you don't spend more more than you make
and you never grow any debt back and
travel the world and have a wonderful
life we're so glad you called wow that
was easy yeah good for her having that
money set aside there it is she's going
to feel so much better about traveling
tomorrow morning